All across European capitals, the number
one name for newborn baby boy boys is
not just Arabic or Islamic. It's
Muhammad.
>> Jimmy Ratcliffe. He's the owner of
Manchester United football club. He's a
very famous, very prominent businessman.
Thought that, you know, Britain had been
colonized in reverse. Of
>> course, he has a point and this goes
back to what we're seeing. It's not just
that, you know, the powers that be are
enabling uh this mass Muslim migration,
but they're also shutting down anyone
who dares notice it. Western people have
been so conditioned to accept that sort
of paradigm in their lands.
>> Gays for Gaza is never going to be a
going to be a bit of a reality check
there, isn't it?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So that's my point. I think
uh Muslims are very happy to cynically
ride the liberal wave. Western spirit.
It's already very weak. So uh if it
could not even do the most simple thing,
which is to say no to mass migration.
Now across the west, public debates
raging around questions of identity,
integration, religious freedom, and
social change. Particular focus on the
role of Islam in modern societies. For
many, it's a conversation marked with
both concern and complexity. Joining us
today is Raven Raymond Ibraham, author,
commentator, specialist in Middle
Eastern history and religion and try to
make us all a little bit of sense of it.
Um Raymond, thank you for joining us.
Um, Muslims make up around well to 25%
of the world's population. Some 1.9
billion people um across Britain, across
Europe, across America. We've seen
growing Muslim populations in the last
50 years now account for around a third
of uh of population growth with
declining birth rates across the West.
They're having larger families, more
Christian more Christian-based families
are shrinking. It's just a numbers game,
isn't it? At the end of the day,
>> well, a lot of Muslims certainly see it
that way and they describe it that way
and they even call it um in Arabic. I
can I'm just giving you the translation
of various Arabic terminology, but it
can be referred to as a baby jihad or
basically a demographical jihad. And
lots of Muslim clerks have actually said
this themselves. They've said uh you
know that part of the jihad, as they
describe it, as they call it, is for you
to go and overwhelm them with babies.
And uh you know it's not for nothing
that all across European capitals the
number one name for newborn baby boy
boys is not just Arabic or Islamic it's
Muhammad. Uh you know there's a point
being made here that I think is being
missed on most people in the west but by
and large yes this is actually even has
a doctrinal backing. It's not just that
Muslims are more fertile, which they
are, but it's also seen as a way of
actually coming in and overwhelming and
essentially taking over.
>> If people are openly stating it as fact,
why is it still so hard in Western
society to turn around and draw
attention to that fact?
>> Well, as far as I'm concerned, that's
the ultimate problem because a lot of
people, they'll hear what I say and um
they'll become resentful. They'll agree
and they'll become resentful in general
towards Muslims uh in the west and in
Europe and they'll say yeah Islam is
violent Islam is doing this etc etc but
they need to understand that the current
issue the current crisis is 100% based
on their policy makers their so-called
elected leaders they are the ones who
are doing this and um you know the in as
much as matters get worse and more
alarming they seem to buckle down even
harder uh without without even giving
any rationale especially a lot of these
Western European nations, the UK and
France and some Scandinavian nations
like Sweden and Germany. Um, and it's
interesting too because I' I've done
some recent studies and if you look at
where the most violence um or rise
against both Jews and Christians, it
tends to be in especially almost in the
exact order of those nations that have
the highest Muslim population.
>> Um, and these are from two separate
actual reports that I looked at. Um so
they didn't they weren't even correlated
but apparently the worst was France and
then after it either e either was the UK
or Germany this is attacks on let's say
churches attacks on synagogues attacks
on actual Christians including terrorist
attacks so the issue is uh you know
inherently Islam you can say has an
intolerant streak to it when it comes to
the non-Muslim but the current situation
is such that uh it's being manufactured
in a way because I can look at other
countries in Europe Poland Hungary and
others they don't have this problem.
That's not because they're superpowers
compared to the UK or Germany or France.
It's because of their policy and it's a
very simple um policy they've taken,
which is basically, well, we don't want
that that amount of Muslim migrants in
our nations. So, they don't have a
problem. I just heard a French uh
journalist who returned from Poland
basically say, "Yeah, Poland looks like
Poland. It's still Poland, but France is
not France." And he talked about in
Poland, women can go out dressed any way
they want. whereas in France he a man is
afraid to go out in Paris. Um so again
the importance the I like to get to the
root of the cause and um we can sit all
day and talk about how Islam is
inherently um incompatible with the west
but the the immediate cause right now is
western leaders and policy makers who
are actually behind this. For example in
Spain I just learned they some kind of
blanket acceptance of something like
half a million Muslim migrants. uh yeah
that's really the root cause of the
problem.
>> It felt for a little while that this
conversation was being had more out in
the open. People were uh you know
beginning to point at the obvious facts,
the obvious data and the obvious you
know as you say countries looking
changing and feeling different but then
uh example to in the British uh media
especially today. So James Ratcliffe
Jimmy Ratcliffe he's the owner of
Manchester United football club. He's a
very famous very prominent businessman.
He gave a, you know, a fairly throwaway
quote that he thought that, you know,
Britain had been colonized in reverse by
migration. Um, and yet now of outrage,
condemnation for the British prime
minister, the usual tactics of of
cancellation. But again, he's he's got a
point, right?
>> Of course, he has a point. And this goes
back to what we're saying. It's not just
that, you know, the powers that be are
enabling uh this mass Muslim migration,
but they're also shutting down anyone
who dares notice it and criticizes it
and makes a very plausible statement
such as he did. Of course, this is a
form of colonization. Uh I if you ever
want to know how bad the situation is in
the west visav Muslim migrants, um what
I always tell people is to try to you
know by analogy imagine the same thing
happening in other countries. And I
think um so for example, imagine if I
don't know, let's say in Saudi Arabia
all of a sudden uh in 20 years it's um
you know it's like 20% um Chinese
>> and nobody can criticize the Chinese and
the Saudis are complaining about how the
Chinese are violent and intolerant and
this and that. I think you'll real
immediately as a Western person you'll
be like yeah that's insane. How can that
be? I understand why the Saudis are
upset. But you but it's because Western
people have been so conditioned to
accept that sort of paradigm in their
lands. I don't think they see it
anymore. It's just it's been taken for
granted. They've been so desensitized
and um indoctrinated into thinking
that's their role. You have to be this
nice guy. You have to allow everyone in.
You can never in any way, shape, or form
say anything, no matter how common
sensical it may be. Um and it's and it's
something that every other civilization
would say if the same thing was
happening to them. So it's really if you
step back and look at what's happening
in the particular example you gave and
what's just happening in the UK and
elsewhere
it really borders on the surreal if you
were to think about it vice versa
another another civilization going
through this of course it would look
like colonization everyone would call it
that because that's exactly what it
would be and what it is I mean a couple
of decades ago when I was at school when
I was growing up we were taught this
multicultural success story was all was
all a great thing and I do think there
were further there were there there were
bigger strides to ingratiate and
integrate um in decades past than there
are now it feels um is that a fair
assessment you think or are just looking
at through blinkers and it looks like
that actually Muslims in particular are
now congregating and living together in
closed shop communities in a way that
actually this this promise of
multiculturalism and integration is it
it just doesn't match up with reality
does it
>> yeah well and there's several reasons
for this one is um you have a much
better chance of say foreign peoples um
entering into let's say Europe and
assimilating when their numbers are
smaller which is always the case because
uh because they have to assimilate they
have no choice uh you know everyone
around them is the host country so they
become one with them and they want to
assimilate and they learn the language
and they do adopt the culture to some
degree or other but when you bring them
in very very large numbers then they
don't need to assimilate and they can
ghettoise and they can basically create
a a parallel society where you know a
lot of people a lot of these Muslim
migrants in Europe have lived there, I
understand, for decades and they don't
speak a word of the language of the
nation that they live. Um, so I think a
reflection of it is it's based on is
based on the numbers and and the larger
the numbers are, the more they will not
assimilate. Why should they? Because
they're going to congregate and create
their own niche, you know, their own
enclaves um no-go zones as they're as
they are, I believe. And um they don't
assimilate. And then I think another
reason um is that it's interesting
because if you look at the younger
generations and the generation those
Muslims who have actually been there for
two or three generations they tend to be
even more radical and um I think there's
the reason for that is uh the original
generations the older ones that came
whatever maybe in the 80s or '9s
>> again they were smaller and they were
willing to um assimilate but in as much
as uh young Muslims grow or even if
they're born in Europe up, but they grow
up and everyone around them is Muslim.
Um, and that's who they hang out with
and that's who they know. And from from
birth, they see the other the the host,
the infidel of that particular European
nation as the other at best and as an
infidel at worst, which has its own
entire categorical condemnation in
Islamic theology. Um but I also think uh
the reason that the newer generations
are so-called radical more radical
>> is a reflection and a response to
western weakness. So the more that
western nations appease and give in and
say oh don't don't wave the St. George
flag for example that doesn't actually
um that doesn't um impress younger
Muslims. that actually uh convinces them
more and pushes them more into what's
called radicalization because they grow
to have contempt and they learn to
despise the host people. Uh Muslims by
nature despise liberal ideology and
liberal uh they'll use it, they'll
exploit it, they'll befriend liberals
and ride that wave to get what they
want, but they really really look down
on the liberal mentality and um it
actually I think um pushes them back
towards their own culture which they see
as more masculine uh more assertive,
more confident and uh so yeah, all of
that together is really is leading to a
combustible situation.
>> It's a combustible situation. There's
also I mean there's there's massive
shades of what we've seen in in New York
with the election men what we've seen in
Minnesota over the the renovations and
renovations from Minnesota in the last
few months the you know just this week
the Sadi Khan the mayor of London a
controversial figure in the eyes of
Donald Trump for for sure but he was
joking uh you know he was hosting a
drinks party and joking about how it
would be the last one because Sharia
Allure is on the way I mean for most
people that's not a laughing matter and
when you look at what's happened
especially in the in the wake of October
7th and the where with Gaza being
exploited with the sort of union between
the hard left socialists and the sort of
anti-war left-wingers coming together
with the Muslim block voters. Um you
know politics is being slowly taken over
by this right before our eyes, isn't it?
>> It is. Yeah. And there's definitely
there's always and this is the issue
with the so-called left. Um there they
are so easily manipulated by Islamist
types. Um you see this all the time uh
here in in the United States I
>> um Ham Tramik is a city I believe I
think it's in Michigan or Minnesota and
it is one of the it's one of the cities
that I think uh um has a has currently a
Muslim majority in the um city council
>> and it's interesting because up until
then so the whole city had a large
Muslim population of course and um if
you looked at it the whole time the
leftist group the the the most liberals
always pushed for even more Muslim
migration and they allied with them and
they supported them and they stood up
for them and then once it became a a a
Muslim majority city council they canled
gay pride events and they cancelled and
the left just was
>> gays gays for Gaza is never going to be
a it's going to be a bit of a reality
check there isn't it
>> yeah yeah so that's my point I think uh
Muslims are very happy to cynically ride
the liberal wave that will help them but
um they are much more against actual
liberal ideology ology and sociology
than they are against conservatives and
what's called right-wing. They actually
are more aligned in thinking with that.
So yeah, in this case, liberals and
leftists are are definitely useful
idiots.
>> But that alliance is going to end in
tears, right? We've seen it on the trans
issue with the um with the the formation
of a of a hard left party, the United
Kingdom. It lost half its Muslim MPs who
refused to go along as you know, as I
just said there, you know, the gays for
Gaza in their t-shirts. you know, would
be literally thrown off buildings if
they ever if they actually turned up on
a on a street run uh by by Hamas. That
union can't hold, right? It's going to
explode. Just going to collapse under
the the contradictions of its own of its
own disagreements, right? Well,
>> you would think, but and this is what
really makes you wonder about the left
and what their true agenda is. It's uh
>> you know, it makes you wonder because
it's it's almost like uh they they both
see it as the enemy of my enemy is my
friend. And apparently the left's enemy
is I don't know a sort of Christian
civilization, something with morals,
something with restraint. And so they're
trying to break it down with Islam by
allying with Islam and empowering Islam.
Um in other words, I think because
otherwise it doesn't make sense. You
would think even they would see through
the fact that uh you know these these
Muslims are the first to want to throw
them over a building uh because of what
they believe. But they still um so
they're either really really stupid or
um they the agenda is such they're so
they're driven by such a hatred for the
normal order and they want to tear it
down any which way. So they're happy to
ally with a very dangerous element that
could and will turn on them once the the
time comes.
>> So I mean we're seeing our you know our
towns, our villages, our cities, our
high streets, our shops, you know taken
over uh and looking very different. It's
seeping into our politics. Have we are
we at a tipping point or have we passed
the tipping point where it becomes too
late? How do we start? You know, we're
having this conversation. Uh others, I'm
sure, are having this conversation and
we're trying to avoid cancellation
[laughter] at all at at all times. But
how long before actually we reach a
point where it the conversations don't
matter? The talking needs, you know, is
beside the point and white people become
a minority as they are in large parts of
central London. uh and the Islam is
Islamification of Western societies
reaches a critical tipping point.
>> Well, I mean the the I think that point
is already here and um or let's put it
this way, if nothing happens now, it's
just going to get worse and worse and
harder and harder to rectify.
>> It already is at a at a tipping point.
you know, nations like the the United
Kingdom and France and the nations that
have a very large Muslim population,
even if they were to adopt today the
most restrictive um conservative
migration, immigration policies, it's
you still have to live with I don't know
10 to 15% Muslim population. Okay? And
this is now there's a point of no
return. What are you going to do with
that? Um and a lot of them are are not
integrated or hostile. It's it's a known
axiomatic fact wherever you have large
Muslim populations there's a large
criminal spike as well in in in in those
nations. Everyone knows that. So in into
certain regard it is a point of they've
already reached that point. A lot of
these western European nations
>> um so and every minute they wait every
month every year it gets worse and
worse. Um and in as much I think the
system is really broken because if you
think your leaders are going to do
something about it I don't think so. So
I think even you might get some who
speak well and and I hopefully if they
get elected they do something but it
seems like a lot of them talk the talk
but when they make it into power they
don't walk the walk you know for various
reasons maybe it's it's so difficult to
actually do anything at this point
>> exactly on that on that exact point what
can you do because as you as you said
even if you had zero net zero migration
you closed the borders uh and had no
more people populations are still
growing you know Muslims are third
fourth fifth generation I in Britain and
they're growing as we've discussed at a
faster rate. Parts of Britain now 35%
Muslim, you know, parts of Birmingham,
you know, is I think it's even higher
than that. What do you do? What do you
do about it? Because even if you do shut
the borders and that's, you know,
probably going to be a fairly radical
solution, what do you do about the
Well, it's a matter of of homegrown
integration, isn't it?
>> Yeah. And this is why it's become a
bigger, much permanent problem. If you
look at the nations that I mentioned who
have a very strict who've always had a
strict migration policy, Hungary, Poland
and others, they don't have to deal with
this. And now because of the liberal
policies, you these nations now have a
serious problem that no matter what they
do, you have to live with. And it's
going to get worse because um you know
what some solutions is to what? Crack
down and get get uh more serious on
radicalization in European countries.
Well, the response is going to be
extreme violence and animosity from the
Muslim groups themselves. It's going to
become like a war zone at one point. And
but if you wait and you sit back and do
nothing and hope it gets better, well,
the Muslim groups are going to get
bigger and stronger. Uh it's it's it's
going to come eventually it's going to
come to a head and ones one or one
group's going to win out and it's going
to
>> What does that look like
>> exactly? You know, it's it's if you it's
either going to be European host people
taking over whichever way they can. I
don't know how that looks. It's not
going to necessarily be pretty. It's not
going to be orthodox in the in the
mainstream political sense. But if they
don't, uh, Muslims in as much as their
numbers grow, they will absolutely. And
and they'll be very happy and proud and
unabashed about doing it because that's
uh that's a good thing. They're bringing
Islam to the light of these infidels and
they definitely need it. So, um, yeah,
in other words, these liberal policies
which were supposedly altruistic have
now put European nations in a position
where it's going to have to get ugly one
way or the other.
>> I got into hot water when I was back in
the UK uh over the new year for saying
was one part of my sort of New Year's
predictions that, you know, violence and
disorder and riots on the street um were
was something I was almost guaranteed to
happen in in 2026, which sort of chimes
what you're saying. And when I as a as a
as a Brit in the United States, people
sort of one of the first questions
people ask me is a sort of bafflement of
what is going on in Britain. How have
you got to this stage? It took Elon Musk
to to sort of have a crystallizing
moment on on on Pakistani rape gangs,
the grooming gang scandal which has been
going on for 25 years in Britain of
headlines, but we've never been never
had that sort of reckoning that moment
where in America it feels like they're
not quite at the tipping point of Europe
is and Europe is being held up as a as a
sort of example of how not to do it. Do
you think that's fair or do you think
there are parts of the United States
that are already too far down that line?
>> The United States is also pretty far
down that line, but not with Muslims per
se, just the immigration problem in
general. um is of course a large problem
with lots of mill you know many millions
of illegals and in as much as the Trump
administration and ICE are doing what
they're doing as I understand it they're
bas they're barely you know with
everything and the deportations of the
criminals and the worst of the worst
they're barely making a crack or a dent
um in in as much as how many illegal
ending criminal element migrants are in
the United States who are not
necessarily Muslim but I think Europe's
issue is a lot more existential because
whereas uh in the American situation is
maybe it's it's a problem for the US
identity and it's an it's a an
overwhelming of these different you know
illegal groups in Europe it's
existential because if you go back
throughout history Islam has been
itching to conquer Europe for centuries
and has been trying to conquer Europe
and and uh it was seen as the final
bastion. Okay, this is actually my field
history. Islam wag continuous jihads on
Europe and they made inroads in Spain
and into France and conquered the
Mediterranean islands and of course the
Balkans under the Ottomans and so forth.
So this has been a long-term project and
um here and lo and behold you find
Muslim migrants who who still have the
same mentality and the ideology this
sort of supremacist uh takeover speaking
openly about it and now their numbers
are growing and growing. And what are
the European leaders who brought them in
doing? They're shutting down their own
people from even noticing and talking
about this anyway, which again really is
very curious why that is even happening.
You know, political correctness is one
thing, but this has gone really
overboard and people in Europe need to
open their eyes to what's going on. No
one wants to hear this is a conspiracy
theory or anything of that matter. But,
you know, it gets to a point where you
have to ask yourself either whatever
these people are doing, their decisions
are horrible and they're destroying my
country. Whether it's because they're
involved in a conspiracy or whether they
are complete um imbeciles at this point
it almost doesn't matter. They need to
be kind of taken out and uh you need
actual pe you need people who can govern
the European nations who actually care
about the welfare of those nations.
>> You've called this a 1200 year uh
conflict that sort of restarted uh you a
brief pause for a moment but has
restarted. What does a definitive
victory look like and how is it you you
sort of skirt around and say look things
need to get ugly things need to get hard
and tricky but what in your view
actually could and needs to be done
>> you mean for western peoples Muslim
>> peoples for western peoples
>> um okay so of course
>> we're saving the western
>> yeah yeah yeah I I thought you might
want to know what their ultimate goal in
>> well I mean well yeah well I mean the
problem the two go hand in hand because
there's a conflict there
>> very symbiotic actually but as far as
the west is concerned um so of course
the uh the completely hardcore
elimination of migration um everywhere
and anywhere anyone who's in Europe uh
who's illegal should also be sent back
anyone who's inol involved in criminal
activity any or terrorism or so forth
yeah you forfeited your stay as well
okay uh I mean these are very simple
survival survivalist type of things that
any any other country would do this and
no one would ever in any way shape or
form form complain about it. Okay, so
that's just a simple start right there.
Um, you're going to have to figure out
this business about, you know, you have
mosques everywhere who are preaching
Islam and Islam isn't I mean, you can
tell everyone it's peaceful, but it's
not. That's not what's being preached in
these mosques. So, I don't know. Do they
have to have surveillance in mosques
surve or or and censorship over the
dissemination of Islamic literature that
is reaching people in European
countries? All of what especially the
the radical uh stuff. I mean, these are
all um measures that wouldn't be needed
to take. But of course, if that does
happen, you can expect a massive um
backlash from Muslim populations,
especially the larger ones in Europe,
and they will be framed. And here again,
the dumb leftists will come and help
them as this is an attack on our
religion. This is an attack on our our
freedom of religion and exercises of our
religion. And of course, leftist
elements will help them. So, this this
is the quagmire that people are in that
that that the west is in. you know, it's
not going to be easy and in as
[clears throat]
so far when one looks at the western
spirit, it's already very weak. So, uh,
if it could not even do the most simple
thing, which is to say no to mass
migration, I don't think it's going to
be able to do what's necessary when you
have them right there in your country.
>> I think it's worse than that. I think
it's far from saying no. They've run run
towards the sound of gunfire on it. is
positively being encouraged like an
almost quai religion that sort of open
borders and and and reverse colonization
is something to be welcomed. I think
there's so much guilt especially in
Britain. There's so much sort of
postcolonial guilt that actually we sort
of had we had to celebrate this
takeover. This guilt thing is really
absurd and ridiculous and it is in fact
it's so weaponized uh intentionally and
anyone who understands anything about
history I don't even think the UK what
does the UK or Britain have to be feel
guilty about because they went into
Muslim countries and colonized them well
you know those Muslim countries went
into Europe and killed and slaughtered
and uh didn't even colonize they just
burned the places down to the ground and
nothing would grow there's areas in
Spain that are completely devastated and
can't they're still infertile because of
the Islamic um wars during those
centuries at least. You know, you can
say that Europe, England and so forth
when they came to um and colonized you
know what they brought with them they
brought medicine and technology and
progress and governance. If you look at
the writings of uh Muslims from nations
I've I've looked very deeply especially
in Egypt that's my ancestry is from
Egypt and um you know if you look at
during the colonial era people spoke of
the Egyptians themselves Muslims and
Christians spoke about Egypt as this was
the best time uh because uh we were
lifted up from where we were basically
living in darkness under the Ottomans
and there was no progress no technology
no science Europeans brought so much
good stuff with them you can criticize
them for how they ruled or whatever
ever. But you know, again, if you keep
it in a historical context, just think
of what Muslims did to European nations.
You know, very few people I mean, how
many people in in England realized that
there's a island there called Lundy that
Barbrey Muslim pirates of North Africa
used as a base and actually raided
England and Baltimore and Ireland and
Denmark and gathered uh European slaves
to take to Barbary North Africa and
sell. Okay. Um but for some reason,
Muslims never need to feel bad about
that. Only recently, Algeria of all
nations criticized France for
colonialism um and saying it wants
reparations and an apology. But as I
mentioned, well at least France brought
so much good stuff during those years.
But you know what Al Algeria did? Well,
Alers was the capital of the slave trade
and that is where about 1.2 million
Europeans were actually sold through
Alers. So this is the hypocrisy you know
France let's say or the UK are supposed
to feel guilty because of colonialism
whereas what the Muslims did which is so
much worse and brought nothing positive
with it. It was just death and
destruction and slavery that goes by no
one mentions that and that never makes
it into the equation. Yeah, I'd say the
reparations are already being paid in
civil service, in in infrastructure, in
in roads, in railways, in postal
services, in telecommunications, you
know, which was spread spread at a rapid
rapid speed, but going down we're going
down a different path there. Um, you
seem I don't know, cynical is the wrong
word, but it's kind of gloomy about the
prospects. You talk about the the sort
of fundamental weakness at the heart of
the heart of the West. Is there anyone
in the sort of political or cultural
arenas in in any country that you think
is saying is not only saying the right
things, there's plenty of people saying
the right things, but has political
capital, the will uh the charisma uh to
be able to lead uh a charge back that's
so you say is so needed.
>> You know, there's not many. There's a
few, but if if you want to talk about
about a political leader in Europe, I
would probably say Victor Orban of
Hungary. Um, because he's he's he
understands things and the way he
speaks, he speaks through civilizational
terms. He'll flat out say, "We don't
want Muslim migrants in our nation
because we know what it is to live under
Muslim control and he'll cite the, you
know, 150 years of Hungary being under
Ottoman Islamic control." So, he has a
long picture. He speaks through
civilizational lines. These are so kind
of uh you know anathema amongst western
politicians to even cite history or
something like that. Um but that's that
is what's needed. You need someone with
a clear sight about history and Islam
itself and the long relationship between
Islam and Europe. Um instead of just
this, you know, crazy progress and
everything's jettisoned out and it's
just we have to be nice and nice and
give more and more and they'll like us.
Uh all of which is just a horrible
combination that that provokes the exact
opposite. So um yeah, someone like him
and and again you know you look at his
country uh and I I read something about
for example and he said that in Budapest
is one of the safest places for Jews. He
said this a couple months ago and it was
validated by various Jewish um media
said yeah it is actually which is kind
of ironic because um Budapest is also a
Christian nationalist nation compared to
most of Europe. Yeah. And we often hear
that Christian nationalism is very bad
and it's you know it it's can be
anti-semitic and so forth. So it's very
interesting to see that the two can live
you know side by side and then so and
you know as I mentioned well where are
Jews actually being attacked it's in
those nations that are not Christian
nationalists and are known for their
secular liberalism and humanism France
the UK Germany
>> street the streets of Manchester the
streets of London the streets of New
York frankly
>> exactly and who's attacking them well
it's not Christian nationalists it's
actually Muslims so yeah you need
someone who's who who he's he's the only
one I can think Not necessar And also
ironic that he's basically considered in
in polite European society. Victor Albin
is a dirty it's a dirty word to even say
the EU hate him. I think Trump kind of
gets it. But um you know his fellow
European leaders perhaps aside from some
of the polls you know absolutely despise
him.
>> I know and that but and that and that
right that you're absolutely right.
First of all the first time I heard of
Victor Orban was in 2015. That was when
he was basically introduced to an
American uh media, American public. And
he was basically presented as Hitler
incarnate, you know, a very evil man,
just hates people in general and etc.,
etc. And then you come to find out,
well, it's because he's actually doing
the right thing by his people. He's
putting them first. He's putting his
culture, his religion, his civilization,
and the defense of his nation first. And
lo and behold, now there's no problem.
Okay? the Islam doesn't overwhelm
Budapest from or or Hungary in general.
From what I understand, the all of
Budapest has I think one mosque, I
believe. Um, you know, and then uh so so
he's actually been proven right. Uh if
you look because I've been studying this
for a while, you know, the migrant
crisis began 2014 15 and he said no and
you know, he was attacked. Oh, you're an
evil person. Now you fast forward, it's
been over a decade. Well, his nation,
you can walk in the streets at night and
feel safe. Whereas all the nations that
are still calling him the monster, their
countries, their host populations are
being terrorized. [snorts]
>> I mean, look at the polls. The polls as
well got it, I think, got it pretty uh
pretty bang on despite taking a lot of
heat and being accused of being Nazis
and and all and all the rest. Just
finally on reflecting on on on the sort
of wider society, places like Poland and
Austria are doing pretty well
comparatively to London, to France, to
Germany. uh America aside, but you know
40% of of of Muslims in the UK live in
some in in in the most poorest parts of
the country. Do you see a link between
productivity and economic contribution
to between religion and uh and output?
>> Well, I mean, yeah, you see, you know,
come back to Minnesota and this Somali,
you know, scandal, for example.
>> God, God knows what's going on in
Britain. I mean, they won't even scratch
the surface of that, but if if if
similar wheezes are going on there, I
have no doubt.
>> Well, they they absolutely are. This is
uh there's actually in from Britain, you
may know this man. Um he's an imam. I
don't know if he's in jail now or he
was, but um Chowry something
>> Chowry. Yeah. Nasty piece of work.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I debated him once, but he
also there was a video of him where he
actually boasts about it's of course we
as Muslims come to Britain and we get
all the welfare and we squeeze every
last bit because that's Jiza. Jiza in
Islamic uh Jewish prudence is what
conquered Christians and Jews have to
pay tribute to to their Islamic
overlords. Okay. And that's in Quran
9:29 for example. And um yeah,
absolutely a lot of Muslims do see it
that way. We're living in the amongst
these filthy infidels. We're going to
squeeze them for every penny and we're
going to do it illegally. Of course,
there are a lot a lot of scams going on
both in the United States and of course
all throughout Europe and in Britain
especially. And but that's part for the
course. That's just the logic. They
don't it there's no ethical dilemma for
a Muslim to do that is what I'm trying
to tell you. This is actually, you know,
then they help each other. It's it's an
actual, you know, network that works
together as we've seen with the Somali
thing.
>> Fascinating. I mean a bit downbeat
actually having had a chat with you I'm
afraid sir I mean you kind of put me in
a sort of you know past the point of no
return do you have any sort of slivers
of silver lining for us that it might
not be too late
>> the thing with me you know I have a very
long view of everything I don't just uh
look at the temporal I'm hedgehog not a
fox if you're familiar with you know
that that that analogy I just look at
the big big long picture and um you know
Islam and the west Islam and Europe
Islam and everyone actually have been
struggling I think from the beginning
and uh by and large Islam has not
changed. It hasn't reformed in any way,
shape or form. It's uh if you listen to
them the way I do, I speak Arabic. I
watch lots of videos, live videos, stu
satellite. It's the same idea, you know.
Yeah, we're we're going to conquer
Europe where we want to conquer. And
they don't see themselves as the bad
guy. You have to understand they see
themselves as a good guy. Okay. So,
which is feeling guilty. Yeah. They
don't feel guilty. They feel empowered.
uh taking the money from the dumb
infidel bringing Sharia you know this is
we're the good guys we're doing this
altruistically for you so that goes a
long way to I think um you know uh
mobilize them and empower them in that
sense u but it's the problem is the west
is just you know I write my history's um
you know I write books for example one's
called defenders of the west and it
chronicles lives of Christian defenders
from Europe who fought back you know
let's say king Richard and the crusades
and lot scanderbeg uniatti and so forth
And um if Europe was actually very weak
compared to Islam during these days and
they did what they had to do to prevent
Islamic takeovers uh you know the battle
of tours in 732 okay they fought tooth
and nail to preserve their way of life.
So it's really um it's like I say it's
surreal to fast forward to today and
their descendants are doing everything
possible to empower the uh you know the
ancestral enemy of their civilization
and the ancestral enemy is acting just
like they always have. Uh so there so so
there's a lot of continuity from Islam
where there's a massive discontinuity
and break in how westerners are
responding. It's not only that they
don't understand what Islam's about.
going out of their way to empower it and
spread it in their nation. And the worse
it gets and the more they suffer, they
just buckle down and do do it more. And
that's why if there's any sliver or any
silver light lining anywhere,
>> it's not going to it's going to people
have to take charge. You got to take it
into your hands. The system's broke. The
system's not going to help you. And the
and and the worst part is the longer you
wait, the worse and harder it's going to
be.
>> A warning for the West. Thank you for
joining us. Raymond Ibraham there with
well frankly a fairly chilling
assessment of the state of affairs. Come
back and see us soon. I'd love to chat
more. Um thank you for joining us today.
>> My pleasure. Thanks for having me.
>> Thank you.
>> Bring the fire and the rightous name.